so you know exactly how to use twin
motion and you've been using it for a
while now
but you're struggling to color grade it
and make it look professional
today i'm going to show you exactly how
you can color grade
all of your twin motion exports with one
click premiere pro luts
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and i'm a practicing architect
in australia
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me today we're talking
about premiere pro luts
and how you can take your twin motion
exports and make them
so much better just a couple days ago we
made a video
about lightroom presets for twin motion
photo exports
so if you're interested in that make
sure you check that out down below as
well
nonetheless today we are talking about
how you can take your video between
motion exports
and take them to the next level so i'm
going to walk you through how you can
install these luts and apply them to any
project now just like last time i'm also
going to be giving away
five of these lut packs so you can be
anywhere in the world to win these all
you have to do is
one subscribe to this channel two follow
me on instagram and three
leave your instagram handle in the
comments below
let's get started today by installing
these luts
directly into premiere pro so there are
a number of ways that you can install
these presets into premiere pro
you can do the permanent installation
which i'm going to show you now
or you can do the temporary installation
it's completely up to you
if you download the presets pack with
the link down below it comes with some
installation instructions so you can
follow it step by step
any problems just let me know today i'm
going to show you how to install them
permanently on a windows machine
the steps are very similar for a mac
it's basically just copy and paste
okay so all you need to do is open up
your local disk drive on your pc go to
this pc
open up the c drive and then you want to
move to program files
and locate adobe so adobe's usually at
the top because it starts with a and
then you want to locate the common file
under common if there is no luts folder
already
installed what you want to do is right
click new
folder and it's going to just say
luts you want to copy that letter for
letter
case for case so all uppercase lut and
lowercase
s and then you want to go inside that
folder again and create two more files
you want to create one file called
creative and one more file
called technical
downloaded file with all the luts in it
go into the creative file
and highlight all of these again right
click
copy and paste
and there you have it that's installed
perfectly on to premiere pro
so if we open up premiere pro now all
those luts should be there
what we want to do is open up the
premiere profile locate the luminentory
color
on the right hand side if you don't see
that you can always go to window at the
top
and check mark luminatric color so
because it is open for us and because
we've permanently installed it
it would usually be under import luts if
you're doing it temporarily
however because it's a permanent install
we want to go down to creative
and then under look we will find all our
brand new installed luts
so if we flick through these quickly you
will see how much of a
change it makes to this individual photo
so autumn external automatically makes a
huge difference
but because this is an internal shot we
don't want to be using autumn external
we want to be using
autumn internal so you can see now that
all the colors are green and orange and
not
really looking correct so if we come
down and change that to autumn
internal you will once again see how
much of a difference that makes
all of a sudden that photo there and
that video there
looks like autumn it is it has those
natural yellow rays coming in it's nice
white bright and clear
and if we play that video through you
can see it's perfectly color graded
throughout
now let's say for example we didn't like
that autumn look we wanted to be a
little more dark and moody and
mysterious
if we came back across to that color
creative section under look
and locate winter internal because it
again it is a winter internal shot
that we're looking for it'll recolor
grade that to this
beautiful dark moody ambience vibe
that looks incredible so if we play that
through again
you'll notice that those exterior colors
are color graded correctly the interior
colors are perfect and that this color
grade has been specifically made for
twin motion exports
now what happens if your color grade
goes from indoors to outdoors
well all we have to do is find where
that outdoor transition
is cut our project at the bottom select
the secondary video and instead of going
to winter internal
changing that to winter external now we
see that the external has been color
graded a little bit differently making
it darker and moodier again
with the lights shining through that
pool so it makes it look
light and vibrant overall there is eight
presets in this pack that you can
utilize
we have two for every season one for
indoors and one for outdoors
so if you need a more summer look a more
fresh look you can always use the summer
internal or the spring internal
and then you have the more moodier and
color graded ones like autumn for those
orange colors
or the winter for the darker moodier
tones and that's all for me today guys
very quick lut video to showcase how
quickly and how easily
you can improve your twin motion video
exports
if you need anything further from me
make sure you leave a comment down below
i'm always happy to help i will try to
reply to absolutely everybody
the link is down in the description if
you want to grab one of these presets
for yourself
otherwise the competition will run for
30 days from the post of this video
i will announce the winners on my
instagram story so make sure you are
following me on instagram
and leave your instagram down below so i
can actually select a winner because
this video forms one of my 28 videos
in 28 days for february of 2021
it would usually be i'll see you next
monday however because we are still in
february
i will see you tomorrow